2015 showed that the Internet is a
dangerous place whether it's your
cellular connected Jeep or personal
details on the adulterous dating site no
one is safe from hackers so let's look
back at the top five security stories we
covered this year our number five story
was a major win for the feds and a hard
lesson for the dark web that anonymous
activity is sometimes not so anonymous
after two years in prison Silk Road
mastermind Ross Ulbricht finally went to
trial and was convicted of running the
billion-dollar black market for drugs
his sentence life in prison without the
possibility of parole our number four
slot this year is taken by the
encryption debate whether the Isis
recruits responsible for the Paris
attacks in November used encrypted
messages or not the US government used
it as an opportunity to call out
companies like Apple and Google for
refusing to give law enforcement
agencies backdoor access to protected
communications one might assume that the
head of the CIA would have Fort Knox
like digital security but even CIA
director John Brennan experienced a
nightmare security breach this year when
hackers broke into his personal AOL
email account and released some of his
private messages the leaked documents
didn't involve classified material but
did contain highly personal information
hacking the Internet of Things took our
number two slot when two guys from st.
Louis showed us how it's possible to
remotely hack a cheap by disabling its
transmission or breaks okay hold on
tight hold on the attack they
demonstrated spook the automotive
industry led to the recall of 1.4
million vehicles and even helped spur
legislation aimed at establishing new
digital security measures for cars but
they weren't the only ones attacking IOT
devices this year electronic skateboards
computerized guns and critical medical
devices were all in the sights of
hackers this year finally our biggest
story of the air at cheaters greatest
nightmare was the hack of Ashley
madison.com a sight for people seeking
extramarital affairs when the hacker or
hackers released the private details of
many of the sites 32 million users they
exposed affairs for all the world or
more worryingly for the spouses and
partners of Ashley Madison
to see the leak not only ruined
reputations and relationships it also
may have contributed to the suicide of
at least two people and proved once
again the secret rarely remains secret
when it's posted online